[Music]
so walmart is being sued
or are we just talking about greeters by
sam's club that don't [ __ ] look at
you but the walmart people look at you
they're nice yeah i feel like walmart's
probably getting sued every year yeah
yeah every month yeah every month right
yeah yeah i don't know this one might
sound like uh it has some grounds
because this guy they're not rolling
over their savings anymore
were they the ones with the uh yeah the
smiley face i'll be slapping prices down
there i love how the price is going
that was very effective down three cents
that's pretty good bro good job on that
campaign so walmart's being sued by a
guy who purchased a portable phone
charger you know a little charger blocks
had it in his back pocket and it
spontaneously exploded
causing severe chemical burns to his ass
remember that was the thing with the
droids for like five years they're like
you got a jordan can't come on the
airplane it's like a samsung [ __ ] but
why is that
why is that walmart's fault is it their
branded battery or some [ __ ] he bought
it there i don't know maybe they're
supposed to have some kind of like uh
assurance when something breaks right
you you have a factory warranty
that like whatever retailer doesn't fix
it you go like even if you get it at
target or wherever it goes it goes to
the manufacturer yeah so i'm like why
did walmart maybe because they have the
most money or it's different than just
breaking too like causing bodily harm
did he sit on it he might be super
multiple if they're willing to stock it
i don't know yeah you think if it's a
normal thing they'd it's their
responsibility to rip it off the shelves
yeah and at the end of the day they
probably got insurance for this [ __ ]
anyway sure so that's probably why it is
huh yeah like they look for the company
they're like oh this china company
doesn't even exist anymore let's go to
walmart do i feel like that's half the
companies in the world like you buy
something on amazon it's like not even a
company it's not even brand it's just
like a plum it's just a thing yeah yeah
from the water like everything's just a
thing now
it's weird you'll see the same product
with different names like ding ding
electronics or something it's a sales
funnel but it's literally the same [ __ ]
for the same alibaba i feel like the
opposite of the 90s like 90s is all
about brands like i ain't drinking rc
cola i'm only drinking coconut oil
you know but now it's like nah whatever
dude it's brown and it's bubbly
brown it's like they're blind test pepsi
or coke they tell us now it's like they
were actually the same the whole time
that would [ __ ] me up yeah it was all
from ellie
it's actually shasta rc yeah shasta you
could tell
i love
do you remember back in the day they had
generic soda machines outside of
supermarkets yeah all right so like you
crush cans you do what you can right and
then like you can find like like 20
cents you put that [ __ ] in there and
you get a soda for like 20 cents and i'm
just like damn i got this [ __ ] for cheap
dude what's that now though it's like a
bug 50. yeah oh yeah it is yeah you know
what's bomb nothing beats a ice cold rc
cola on rollerblades
what do you mean all right like when
you're rolling
were you drinking it while you're
rollerblading are you from greece
lightning what the i love that moment of
silence
are you from the air up there are you a
big rollerblader when it's hot in the
summertime and you're just rollerblading
around we got denim shorts on too ass
cheeks hanging out
get that rc cola
does gio know you rollerblade
yeah in i home do you even know you
rollerblade yeah yeah this is a new
thing no dude
i got something they used to call it
aggressive skating you know you guys
have handsome aggressive in-line
hanson's handsomes yeah
yeah yeah yeah did you drink that
thinking i was hella healthy they
secured that trader joe's yeah that was
hella healthy it's still tasty yeah they
sprained it so good you're like there's
fruits on it yeah this is healthy it's a
vitamin drink so how bad is this a guy's
ass bro it's pretty bad it's not um we
got pictures no i wish there was so much
yeah but yeah the dude uh
he needed to get skin grafts and the
first time they tried to staple into
place it didn't hold like it
would his cake his cakes they just tried
to staple like cake oh my gosh cake on
them right
yeah they try to do a little cake
stapler hello bob dude yeah enhance that
thing while you're back there dog the
sucky thing about this which which is
like a total other problem is they had
to like issue him fentanyl and morphine
and like things to like deal with it
which could cause a whole lot for sure
no you could be addicted yeah so we had
to get repeated graphs to get it um you
know get that ass looking nice again
what's the what's the uh money does it
say it doesn't say yet it's gotta be
millions walmart is not uh immediately
uh there's no comment yet from them but
yeah he's going to have permanent
substantial scarring with permanent loss
of feeling and nerve damage
in the a ass area yes we don't know the
exact area this is like follows walmart
it's like you get sued you pay whatever
to settle and then you like sue the reta
uh the the the product or the
manufacturer how much did walmart pay uh
tracy morgan for the truck hitting him
oh is it a walmart truck yeah i know he
got hit by a truck i didn't know it was
a walmart yeah but you're 100 right
they'll say here's three million now
sign this nda don't ever mention this
again sign it right now give me two
million yeah and then and then they're
gonna go hit up [ __ ] the manufacturer
right and be like give us your money or
whatever [ __ ]
because it was different we did an
article that one time about that lady
who [ __ ] stepped on a rusty nail at
walmart and then it [ __ ] lets her
amputating her leg and like years of
dude you know this is how much they paid
tracy morgan for the walmart truck
hitting
uh no i heard that number i saw an ins
uh 90 million 90 million i heard oh
you think it had something to do with
him being famous though probably in the
sense that he is a sick lawyer it was
for sure and the media about it i need
to get hit by something that's
immediately [ __ ] it was also really
bad because the yeah he got [ __ ] up
the passenger with him
died and then it was a guy i think he
the guy felt like a walmart driver fell
asleep with a wheel or something like
that do you want is walmart one of the
few that probably has their own drivers
right like a lot of places they have
their own logistics but not a lot of
people don't contract it yeah a lot of
people are just truck drivers and they
have like a walmart or whatever
mcdonald's yeah yeah merchandise yeah so
his was pretty bad and also because he's
you know like a writer and if like his
brain's not working right after such a
crash like that but the funny irony is
like after he got his settlement and
then he was driving again he bought a
bugatti the day off the lot someone hit
him no
do you think his brain was insured i
know there's gamers that insure their
hands oh yeah really like if you need
brain surgery or something or if you're
a writer like you know you're like if
anything happens to my brain kind of
like life insurance so my wife would get
this money or whatever like jlo couldn't
your thighs no the same idea she yeah
she got her ass and stuff because if
something if her ass exploded with the
charger then she gets hella money
because now she can't make money i think
so yeah back in the i think in the
[ __ ] um back in the day too yeah
backing jenny from the block he had to
insure something on their body what
would they ensure would you insure your
ears no you're like nick that year
they're not valuable they're not
valuable how do you ensure personality i
guess you could i think you could insure
your brain i'm sure the previous stuff
sure you're a good person i want to
ensure that that's a good one yeah
that's a good one that's what us4 say
it's like hey man your personality
changed you [ __ ] can't do jk news no
more dude and it's like well i can't
[ __ ] work because now i'm good yeah
that's kind of a thing mike's like hey
i'm trying to insure my soul somebody's
like here's a bible yeah i'm trying to
sharpen my three general vibe
yeah dude like my total chills just like
i'm gonna do a vibe check and if she
ain't right i'm hitting up washington
mutual my swag my drip yeah
dude my vibe feels off i'm ready to
collect how can i ensure my energy cause
like man i gotta stay lit dude like i
stay lit i wanna ensure my religious
beliefs that would make sense like a
dancer and sharing their body or
whatever like that oh that [ __ ] makes
sense if you can't do your job anymore
do you think there's any dancer out
there that is insured like they might
not be like wealthy they've been sure
for
oh that's the other thing oh damn it i
want to go there why there's a baller
ass dancer no there's a dancer that that
apparently
allegedly
ha uh got some insurance for um
if sexual misconduct were to happen to
them
that's it i didn't know you could do
that that's a little darker that way you
can do that not not happen to them uh if
they were accused of it oh that's even
done you have you have like a fund for
settlement money to like get someone to
not a slush fund does that work
wow oh [ __ ] for sexual like misconduct
christ that is dark and again that's
like an alleged thing that i heard
that's for sure yeah cosby's getting
[ __ ] tripling down
the best dancer of all of us
yeah i don't know cosby was a dancer
[Laughter]
it's so funny because of the content
that he created and in his [ __ ] crime
that it's like holy crap the most famous
roofie artist of all time
you would never think is he in the
public eye now or not he did i know he's
out
but he's chilling like oj didn't he no i
know didn't he get i think we also did
an article didn't he get offered like uh
some comedy uh stops i i believe yeah no
i mean people will pay bro
people will go to that fresh off uh
fresh out of jail i bet i always got
well some new material new material oh
my god it's like people [ __ ] laughing
their ass off at louis ck like after the
fact you know and then he starts just
seriously talking about the his
situation luis ck's come back from that
[ __ ] was great though he actually got
away can we not yeah can we not compare
them
louie jerked off in a tree you're right
you're right you're right that's true
he's a [ __ ] rapist
he jumped off in a tree i thought i
don't think he literally jerked off in a
tree no i thought he jacked up in front
of his fellow comics he would like bring
people up to his room yeah like wanking
and stuff he would get off on
jacksonville i don't want to put it on
cam you know
he jerked off into a plant in front of a
lady which is much different than bill
cosby roofing folks and [ __ ] raping
them yeah that's completely different
yeah
it's not you guys though but the world
does put them together yeah yeah that's
like the cancel culture issue they just
throw it i'm like dude the moral line
there is nothing because one is murder
and one is maybe getting in a fist fight
yeah right so it's like there's
different levels to this yeah yeah but
in media it's not immediate it's rapist
what happened well that's kind of like
if you become a sex offender if you
expose yourself right so like what if
the plant said yes plant said yes it was
naughty in the sunlight
the ac was blowing it was going like
this what kind of plant is that it's a
consensual chrysanthemum
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you